We know you guys like pirates every time we make a video about pirates,
that gets loads of views. So today we're going to be profiling.
Another heavily requested scallywag of the seas, black Bart Roberts.
But before we do any of that, I want to thank today's sponsor morning brew,
just like a rich cup of coffee.
Morning brew is a totally free daily newsletter that you won't want to start
your day without.
It's a quick well-organized look and it's both the lines and having used that
you can receive every day, Monday through Saturday,
who has the time to sit down and watch the news every morning.
Not me who has the stamina,
just slog through a dry crusty section in your local newspaper,
every single day,
who trusts that Twitter is going to vomit up topics that you definitely need
to know about.
Nobody morning brew tells me what I need to know along with some really cooler,
interesting tidbits that I could keep in my back pocket uses little conversation
starters. So for instance, earlier today, I was reading my most recent copy.
It's the 12th of October.
So that's the one and it had all these good bite size bits of information,
hurricane Delta in the United States, the conclusion of the French open,
which I already knew about stay, you know,
I like tennis and some market transactions I'd have never picked up on
otherwise. There was also a cool story,
how Richard Branson was trying to raise $200 million for Virgin orbit.
So all of that great stuff. So if you like finance current events or TAC,
or even if you just want to keep up with some basic headlines,
there is absolutely no reason not to subscribe to the morning brew. Like I said,
it's totally free and it takes about 10 seconds.
So click the link in the description below and let's get into today's video.
Yeah.
We've used the term most successful pirates here quite a few times in previous
biographics videos,
but that's because there is no single thing that accurately defines the success
of piracy. Black dead was the most notorious of the bunch.
Black Sam Bellamy probably accrued more wealth as a pirate than any other. Well,
Henry every pulls off the single biggest score in history and more importantly,
managed to get away with it. Today.
We are using another metric to establish the periodical credentials of calves in
Bartholomew, Roberts, AKA black bot.
The number of prizes taken that refers to the number of ships that he captured
plundered or ransomed Roberts is credited with well over 400 prizes,
all within the short timeframe of just three years.
One of the men who defined the golden age of piracy,
there was a time when he was considered invincible and every merchant and sailor
in the Atlantic knew and feared the name Bartholomew Roberts.
John Robbins.
This was born in 1682 in the tiny village of little Newcastle in Wales at one
point. So he changed his first name to Bartholomew. We're not sure why or when,
but it was quite common for pirates to use.
Aliases is also well known today by the Monica black box,
which she shares with a wild West outlaw whose real name was Charles Bowles.
Maybe we'll cover someday as well. However, unlike bowls bustling you it,
so it's seemingly never called black box in his lifetime.
Instead this nickname came from a poem written about him hundreds of years
later,
as is the case with all of the other pirates we've covered here on biographics.
We have a dearth of knowledge when it comes to Robert's his early years,
the information we do possess about his periodical career comes to us. Again,
courtesy of Charles Johnson is a general history of the pirates,
which is not incredibly reliable, but I mean, it's what we have to work with.
Unlike many of his compatriots Roberts was a reluctance pirates.
It is believed that he became a sailor from a young age,
but we have no accurate records of his service until 1719.
At that point he was already,
the second is made to bought a slave shed called the princess under the commands
of a captain plumb. In the summer of that year,
the princess sailed to the gold coast of West Africa to pick up slaves from
anima Bowie present day Animoto in Ghana on its way back.
The ship was attacked by pirates under the commands of captain Howell,
Davis himself, a Welshman from the same County of prem Berkshire as Roberts,
the pirates captured the princess and plundered it. If it's valuable loose,
when something like this occurred,
that we usually one of two things that happened to the surviving sailors.
If their ship was still see whether and assuming that the pirates didn't know
what to add it to their fleet, then they were usually free to go.
If the ship could not set anymore,
then the remaining sailors were brought on board, the pirate vessel,
and either placed in a raft or dropped off at a nearby Island. In both cases,
pirates usually gave some of the sailors an opportunity to join them since after
all they needed to refill their ranks, too.
This was typically done on a volunteer basis,
but some men were forced to join up with the pirates whether they wanted to or
not.
Usually this was because they were skilled in an important area like medicine,
carpentry on navigation.
Roberts was among the men forced to join a whole Davis's crew above the Royal
Rover. We're not sure why,
but maybe the captain fancied having a fellow Pembrokeshire native aboard the
ship. And that is how Bartholomew Roberts became the pirate.
[Inaudible].
And also been thrilled with being a pirate at first,
but he soon discovered that he was pretty good at it and eventually took to it
like a duck to water. Again,
we don't know much about his maritime experience prior to turning to piracy,
but it seems that Roberts was a very skilled sailor and an affable person in
general,
he quickly became regarded as one of the most indispensable crewman aboard the
roll robot. He was so popular, in fact,
so that he became the new captain just six weeks after it was abducted from the
princess. His promotion came out of necessity,
not any kind of amnesty towards the previous captain Davis had taken the ship to
the islands of Prince CAEP,
which back then was falling to the Portuguese embark.
He flew British colors and was grounded, safe passage into the Harbor.
His plan was to gain the governance. Trust,
invites him on board the Rover and then hold him for ransom.
It didn't really work out like that.
The governor didn't fall for the Roos and instead planned his own counter
attack. He invited the captain to join him for lunch, pal Davis,
and a small retinue left his ship and traveled to the Island Fort,
but they were ambushed the way and executed with David's dead.
The role Reva needed a new captain.
Charles Johnson describes the election process as being quite offensive.
One like you would expect to see in parliaments and not on a pirate ship
disliking the British parliament, the men were divided into Lords and commons.
The format being made up of officers as well.
The latter consisted of all the regular crew members.
Only the Lords were allowed to propose candidates for the position of captain.
And then everyone voted on it. One Lord's named Dennis proposed Bartholomew.
Robertsons gave an impassioned speech to show his support. He said,
it is my advice that while we are sober,
we pitch upon a man of courage and skilled and navigation.
One who by his counsel and his bravery.
It seems best able to defend this Commonwealth and waters from the dangers and
Tempest seven unstable elements and to the fatal consequences of anarchy and
such a one. I take rods to be a fellow.
I think in all respects worthy of your esteem and favor.
This was enough to go on a cheers from everyone aboard the ship,
except for another Lord named Simpson who presumably had hopes of assuming the
position itself and that's is how Bartholomew Roberts became a pirate captain.
He accepted the promotion sayings that since he had dipped his hands and muddy
water and must be a pirate, it was better being a commander.
Then a common man.
Was in charge.
His first course of action was to avenge the death of his predecessor.
The ship started battering. The Portuguese fought with cannon fire,
but this was all a distraction.
Mental honey to 30 man expedition that had made landfall and was approaching the
Fort on foot. As they took the soldiers inside by surprise.
And the survivors quickly abandoned that post and fled into town.
The pirates then burns the Fort down and pushed all of their cannons into the
sea before returning to their ship.
Some of the men did not consider this sufficient punishment.
Just captain Davis had been quite popular with his crew.
They wanted to burn down the town itself,
but Robert's considered that there was no way to do this without sustaining
heavy casualties.
Especially now that the locals were expecting an attack in the ends,
the crew of the RA Rover compromise, they manned different ship,
which they'd captured in the Harbor sailed into shallow waters near the town and
shelter.
If you can involve these to satisfy the need for revenge on their way out.
So they even found a couple of Portuguese ships and burn them down as a bonus
from there,
the ship sailed back to Anna Mabo is the place where Robinson sporadical career
first started to pick up provisions and performer paths on the way they also
captured a Dutch Guinea men and an English ship called the experiment.
He's captain joined up with black box crew. Anyway, as we said in the intro,
Roberts took over 400 prizes during his three years as a pirate.
Obviously we can't mention every single one. So from here on out,
we're only going to talk about the notable ones.
Once the ship was ready to sail, it needed a destination.
The crew took a vote and selected Brazil.
They embarked on a month long trip and derived at an uninhabited Island off the
coast of Brazil named Fernando,
which served as their base of operations for the months to come.
Robert spent around nine weeks prowling the waters of South America,
but found a very slim pickings when it came to prizes,
he and his group decided to sail to the West Indies. Instead,
as we're getting ready to leave, when they chanced upon a remarkable site,
it was a large Portuguese fleet of 42 ships sitting in Brazil's all saints Bay
waiting for two powerful men of war to escort them back to Lisbon.
Obviously Roberts was heavily outnumbered,
but this did not deter him where other pirates would.
It immediately turned around and set sail as fast as possible.
He simply looked for an alternative strategy.
He didn't engage the fleets in open combat, of course,
but Roberts rackings that's with the elements of surprise on his side,
he could capture one ship and to make us escape before the rest of the fleet
caught on the question was which ship one advantage when dealing with a large
fleet is that it's pretty easy to get lost among them.
The Royal Rover was able to infiltrate the fleet without anybody noticing.
They approached one at the Portuguese vessels and persuaded their ships Mazda to
come on board the Rover only then did he understand the situation he was on the
deck of a pirate ship. If he tried to give any signal or sign of distress,
he would immediately be cut down and his own ship would be attacked and punted
without giving any quarter. Instead,
captain Roberts promised him that he would be returned safe and sound to his
vessel and left alone.
The only thing he had to do was point at the richest ship in the fleet,
unsurprisingly, the Portuguese captain, and found this an offer.
He couldn't refuse and directed the pirates towards the launch 40 gun ship,
which was significantly more powerful than the roll robot.
Even though it clearly was not expecting one of the other ships to open fire in
it. And despite its strength,
the pirates managed to claim this with any two casualties.
They were sailing away by the time the rest of the fleet realized what had
happened. And by then it was already too late to catch up with them.
Once they were safe,
the pirates inspected that plunder and discovered that they had struck the
Motherload. The ship's cargo was filled with valuable goods,
such as tobacco and sugar jewels and precious Jens,
including a gold cross set with diamonds made,
especially for the King of Portugal and over 40,000 Portuguese gold coins.
After that.
The pirate sounds up North or a bit and began prowling the waters off the coast
of Suriname and Guiana. After taking a few more prizes,
tunes changed for Buffalo, Jimmy Roberts,
he had heard of a Portuguese Brigid ezine sailing in those waters and wanted to
plunder it. He assembled a group of 40 men and boarded a sleep,
which was smaller than the Rover, but also faster. Meanwhile,
he left his own ship as well as the captured Portuguese vassal with all the news
and the command of a crew member named Walter Kennedy.
The Snoop had no luck going after the brigand team.
Robert spent eight days trying to catch up to the Portuguese ship,
opposing winds and currents just kept driving and back further.
Eventually the supplies were starting to run out.
So he had to give up the chase, but that's when things went from bad to West,
the Snoop was approached by a boat containing some of the men left behind on the
Rover and they informed Roberts that in his absence,
Kennedy had proclaimed himself captain with the support of some of the men,
the ones still laws Roberts were allowed to depart on the captured Portuguese
prize,
but everybody else took the Raul driver and sailed away it that they'd split the
loot in half before departing so well,
I suppose there's some honor among thieves in the end,
this turned out to be a poor choice for the men who bought the Rover.
Many of them wanted to leave the pirate life behind,
or at least take a break to spend some of the treasure they intended to go to
Ireland, but there weren't any good navigators among them.
So they ended up in Scotland.
The other rowdy pirates started causing problems in every town and village they
walked into. And as many of them were arrested,
one of the local authorities established that they were pirates and they risked
death sentence. So in order to avoid the hangman's noose,
they started giving evidence against each other.
Bleeding do even more arrests and executions. As Walter Kennedy,
he quickly spent most of his share of the treasure.
Then he traveled to London where he was recognized by a sailor whose ship he
wants to tact. It was arrested and executed for piracy in 1721,
back to Robinson, his men often the anger, the betrayal started fading.
They resolved to devise a new way to keep order and try and prevent something
like that from happening again. So they came up with a pirate code.
Now there are lots of misconceptions about the pirate code.
So let's quickly get some of them out of the way black violence pirate code.
Wasn't the only one. There wasn't even the first that we know of,
but given Robert's high profile.
And the fact that his code was described in detail in Charles Johnson's book,
it became the most famous.
We should also point out that there has never been a universal code that all
pirates around the world were somehow obliged to a Bay,
walking up to a pirate and saying.
Paula, the one Paula.
It would not magically stop him from killing you.
Most of the articles in Robinson's code had to do with discipline aboard the
ship and distribution of plunder. Some of them were pretty obvious, no gambling,
no stealing, no fighting a board. The ship, some were a bit weirder.
The 11th article for example said,
the musicians do have a rest on the Sabbath day,
but the other six days and nights, none without special favor,
many of the rules show a discipline that we would not normally associate with
pirates.
All the crewmen were expected to keep that swords and pistols clean and fit for
service. There was a curfew at eight o'clock at night,
and those who wanted to keep drinking or talking or whatever pirates did we're
only allowed to do so above deck,
no boys or women could be brought onto the ship.
If a woman did somehow end up on board,
she was to be guarded by a Sentinel to secure the ladies virtue.
And any attempt to molester would have been punishable by death pirates,
also risked death or marooning if they abandoned their posts during battle.
But that one was to be expected. Finally,
there were a few articles that talked about how the loot was split.
There is a misconception that the captain took most of the treasure,
and that's not true at all. Not only in Robinson's case,
but with most all captains, most men turned to piracy to make money.
And so they would have not accepted to risk their lives just to make money for
somebody else.
Even the hints of such a rule would have resulted in instant mutiny,
no Roberts and presumably most other pirate captains were entitled to a double
shaft meaning that he only took twice as much as any crewman.
The quartermaster also had a double shad.
The master gunner and boatswain took a shower and a half. Well,
all of the remaining offices were entitled to a share and a quarter the and
liquor were divided equally among the whole crew.
And each man was free to enjoy his portion at his discretion unless there was a
scarcity at which point,
a vote of retrenchments would be called for the pirates were even entitled to
workers' compensation. If they lost a limb during service,
they would receive $800 from a public funds and proportionally less for smaller
injuries. This all sounds nice in theory,
but it shouldn't give you the wrong impression about life on board.
A pirate ship in reality pirates were more often than not willing to cheat fight
steal,
rape ends murder just to suit their own desires and trying to keep them all in
line was a constant challenge for the captain and his officers.
It was at the Royal Rover. Robert sent to use his sloop as his new flagship.
He renamed it, the fortunate name he would use for other ships as well,
going forward. Of course, it wasn't as powerful as this form of craft.
So you have to choose this fights more carefully.
He was successful multiple times, but in early 17, 20,
he was chased out of the West Indies by a few well-armed French pirate hunters
who had been assembled specifically to deal with black bot and his elk,
Robert sales North, all the way to Newfoundlands in present day Canada,
where he arguably caused most of his destruction in late June.
He entered the Harbor of Travis,
which was filled with 22 merchant and shipping vessels.
None of them were equipped to fight pirates.
So they were all at the mercy of Buffalo, mew Roberts,
and they found it lacking. The pirate, burned down all the ships,
except for one gallery, which was added to his fleet. Not long afterwards,
Robinson counts at a French convoy of 10 ships, which again,
he destroyed except for another sloop,
which he captained exchanged for the galley.
The prizes kept on coming one after another,
with little to no reprisals from the targets,
none of them were powerful enough to match up against the pirate fleet.
Eventually Robins decided it was time for another change of scenery.
So he sailed back to the West Indies where he continued his plundering ways,
mostly unimpeded.
The worst thing that happened to him was that another one of his officers,
a man named Thomas Ansstas deserted and took one of the ships with a full crew
and went independence. This happens while Roberts was headed to Africa,
because again, he thought it was time to change locations and stirs.
And does man wants to keep sailing the Caribbean.
So they snuck away during the night in Africa,
it was business as usual for Robinson, his crew,
as they kept plundering dozens of vessels Roberts might've liked to dress in
fancy clothes and speak like a gentleman,
but he showed his true Bob Barrack side.
When the captain of a slave ship refused to pay a ransom.
So Blackbaud had his vessels satchel on fire with all the slaves still trapped
in the galley. This happens in January 17,
22 and perhaps in a display of calmer,
the end game for Roberts just a few weeks later on February the 10th,
when he encountered the HMS swallow of the Royal Navy captains by Shalonda Ogle,
this was a 50 gun ship of the line and would have been more than a match for
Roberts even on a good day. And this was not a good day for the pirate captain.
Earlier that morning,
Roberts had taken a prize trading vessel called the Neptune. Consequently,
most of his men had been drinking and partying all day and were completely unfit
for duty.
The swallow would already destroyed one of the other ships in the pirate fleet
on its way to engage Roberts aboard the raw fortune.
Black violence had no intention to fight. He wanted to run away,
but since he was partly surrounded by coastline,
you have to turn around and sail within range of the swallows cannons.
His ship would be exposed to at least one broadside shot.
Johnson's sustaining heavy casualties from one shot was small,
but fortunately was not with Bartholomew Roberts that day.
The first grape shot from the Royal Navy ship had him right in the throat,
killing him instantly as men abate his final wishes and quickly buried him at
sea, but they will to fight a disappeared.
And they surrendered soon after Bartholomew Roberts,
the dread pirate thought by many to be indestructable vid throughout the whole
of the Atlantic. After plundering, hundreds of ships was finally dead.
He was the last of the well-known pirates, all the other ones. Backnet Henry,
every Calico, Jack Black, Sam Bellamy, Charles vane. They all died before him.
So many consider that the end of Bartholomew Roberts also signaled the end of
the golden age of piracy. So really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos, just like this several times a week.
And as always, thank you for that.
[Inaudible].